Hello everybody, hope that you're good.
This video's an update of what I've been
saying on X and my last YouTube videos
over the last month or few weeks.
Just to clarify, I still think
the same thing. I I'm still going with
my primary scenario, okay? And
basically, I do not think that Bitcoin
can recover in a straight line up from
here. I don't think it's going to
recover like this towards all-time
highs. I think that it's more likely
that first we come towards this area
between 83K and 79K.
That is my take.
Again, I might be wrong.
This my idea just for you to criticize
it. But I do see that this is an area
that's more likely because well, we've
been ranging here for over the last 2
months. And to be honest, every time we
come to the local resistance, price
drops sharply. You can see that there,
okay? Every time. It hasn't changed.
What you've seen here
is a very clean rejection. All right?
So,
what I also see here at the range lows
is this very long week in the daily time
frame. Now, I'll remind you that 96% of
long weeks
tend to get filled in all time frames
sooner or later. So,
not believing that this week is going to
get filled
it goes against the odds, okay? So, I'm
loyal to my system and if I see a long
week in any time frame, this daily time
frame, I do believe that it's likely
that it acts as a magnet for price to go
back there, okay? Now,
when we've been rallying here from the
from the mid-range, I've been saying, I
think we'll either get a rejection from
the local resistance like previously or
it's possible that maybe price does a
liquidity run a bit higher towards the
weekly 50 MA 96K and 97K.
Now, it could still happen if price
recovers from here, you could see that
liquidity run, but again, I would be
expecting this area to act as a
resistance and price to drop.
My invalidation would be
if price gets above the high time frame
resistance 100K because that is an area
that you can see price likes to hold at
least for some time. So, I would be
expecting that if price gets back above
100K, it's going to become a real
support. All right? It's a psychological
level where there will be a lot of new
buy orders and it would hold price
above that level, okay? But again,
that's not my main scenario. My main
scenario is that we are either seeing a
rejection
from the local resistance on from this
potential liquidity run that could still
happen, okay? And from there, price
should go down
towards
this area here, okay? To recover and
fill this long week. And maybe here you
could start to see that sweep of the
lows, okay? Or some consolidation in
this area.
Or price losing this area and going to
the next support. Now, if price was to
break through and below this local low
of 80K without the sweep of the lows, so
if price was consolidating below
80K
for quite a long time, then the next
likely scenario is that it goes down to
74K. Now, if we go into the weekly time
frame,
and I'm going quite fast because I don't
want to take too much of your time,
guys. But if we go into the weekly time
frame, and this is just, you know, me
repeating what I've been saying over the
last few weeks, is that you have a
potential sweep of these lows,
okay? At 74K.
That would be the sweep, recover price
back to all-time highs. It's exactly the
same as Nvidia and Google has done.
Let's check very quickly. You've seen
these charts many times, but there you
go. Sweep of those lows and then
all-time highs. You go to Google, you're
going to see the same. Here, okay?
You see price sweeping these lows
and all-time highs. So, Bitcoin
could be up to the same thing. If it
Bitcoin repeated it, it would be that
sweep of the lows of 74K, could go to
73, 72K, then recover the level and
all-time highs. I don't think that 2026
is likely going to be bullish. I do not
see a 75% bear market like previously.
We are so far in a 35%
drop, okay? 75% would take price to
around 30K. I don't I do not really see
that at all. I think that
the lowest Bitcoin could go
is
40%, okay? And that is only 5% extra
from the current
local low.
And it would be that sweep of the lows.
But again, I do not think that that's
going to happen next. Not because I see
that unlikely, but because
price hasn't even got to break the
current range, okay? If price starts to
break through here,
then we can talk about it. But right
now, you know, why would we talk about
it if we are above a current
support, a tight range? We haven't seen
any break or any breakdown.
No signals. So, why would I jump into
conclusions? Right now, all that I care
about is in the short mid-term analysis
this area between 83K and 80K. So, um
I've received some criticism
and again, I don't mind it at all when
you
say arguments I to explain the other
side. In fact, I really enjoy that, but
to be honest, when I say that this was a
clean rejection in on X in the last post
and some people are insulting you
straight away,
it it makes you think that the market
sentiment
when we see even a 5% pump, it it really
changes. So, why not? Why when if if we
do this kind of drop, the market
sentiment would sweep to the other side.
And if I'm going to call here this time
here that sweep of the lows,
I know it's going to happen the
opposite. The people here are going to
also going to insult me, okay? That's
the market sentiment and that is why
any trader
needs to be able to control their
emotions because they're going to play
against you, okay? All we have is the
chart and we play with it. So, that's
pretty much everything, guys. I don't
want to take too much of your time.
Right now,
we are waiting
for a drop to 83K, 80K. Again, this
liquidity run, it could still happen,
but the truth is that this looks like a
good clean rejection. So, I wouldn't be
surprised at all if price starts to
something like this and drop straight
away to this area, all right? So, that's
pretty much what I've been saying. And
at the moment, I'm still feeling very
comfortable with my previous ideas, so
I'm still sticking to them. No need to
change them. Nothing has changed in
Bitcoin really, okay? So, I'm still
going
uh with the same. Now, if we also check
what
we talked in the previous videos, it was
XRP. XRP, it pumped 30% here, okay? When
all the altcoins were pumping maybe
Solana 11%, Chainlink 13%, AVAX 16%, but
XRP and Doge, both of them were pumping
30% more than the rest of the altcoin
market. And I also said
that when that happens with XRP and or
Doge,
is when Bitcoin tends to retrace back
down, okay? And it's an old
trick, but it seems like it's still
working. In the last video, we were
calling for an immediate retrace of XRP
of all this pump and so far it's already
retraced 50% of it in just a couple of
days, you know? So, with XRP, I'm going
with the same. I think that we're still
going to see $1.90 quite soon. It's it's
price action is what it tends to do. And
Solana,
I see the same, okay? We were saying
that at this level here, 145, there was
a strong resistance and it was likely
that if Bitcoin was going to drop again
towards 82K, 80K, Solana also needs to
drop at least back to the support.
Likely could print another deviation.
Okay? And then recover. So,
so far I'm still going with the same
ideas, guys. If something changes, I'll
let you know and maybe I change my my
analysis, but so far I'm going with the
same idea, okay? So, yeah. Thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon.